Captain Marvel makes her MCU debut in a
movie that's higher further and faster
than well other movies I guess also
stage plays and books it's so fast in
fact you may have missed some of the fun
little Easter eggs 90s references and
nods to Marvel lore that the filmmakers
threw in there
but fear not we tracked them all down
for you because we're nice people
Captain Marvel is set back in the day
and the hella cool year of 1995 won't
there it is did you have a rough day
hearing everything from the fashion to
the soundtrack have that 90s feel but
there are also some quick references you
may have missed off the top the usual
Marvel intro card has been updated to a
touching tribute to the late Stan Lee of
course but did you notice that during
his cameo on the train he's reading the
script for Kevin Smith small rats that
movie was actually released in 1995 and
featured one of Stan's original movie
cameos so it makes sense he'd be a bit
nervous and want to run his lines stay
on the man also showed up in Kevin
Smith's 2016 film yoga hosers
so let's move on
[Applause]
caryl first arrives on earth by crash
landing inside a Blockbuster video store
ah that takes me back she immediately
shoots the head off an Arnold
Schwarzenegger stand II for true lies
that film was released in 1994 so it
gives us an immediate sense of what year
it is but it also closes with a
memorable scene of Arnold piloting a
fighter jet just like carol danvers did
when she lived on earth Carol also
quickly picks up and sets down a
videotape of the right stuff
Philip Kaufman's classic 1983 film is
about the early days of the u.s. space
program and follows a number of former
pilots who go to space in an
experimental aircraft just like carol
does a bit later in the movie Nick Fury
references having just seen his very own
alien autopsy he's probably referencing
a popular TV special that aired on Fox
in the year 1995 it supposedly featured
17 minutes of black-and-white footage of
an actual autopsy being performed in
secret on an extraterrestrial by the US
government as if speaking of fury he
identifies himself a few times in
Captain Marvel as Nick Fury agent of
shield
this of course references the title of
his classic Marvel comic book as well as
the 1998 movie versions starring David
Hasselhoff as fury which I'd like to
stress to all of you is 100% real in the
movie Annette Bening skree scientist is
named marvel but while on earth she goes
by the human alias dr. Wendy Lawson now
way back in the Silver Age of comics
when Captain Marvel first debuted he was
a crease by named Marvel who came to
earth and took on the identity of a dead
human scientist his name dr. Walter
Lawson I see what you did there not all
the names were kept totally consistent
from comic to film though in the comics
Carroll's pet cat is named chewy a
reference to Chewbacca from Star Wars in
the movie though they switched the cat's
name to Goose most likely a reference to
Tom Cruise's best friend from the
dogfight classic Top Gun
that cat can be my wingman any day
gooses Fleur can powers remained pretty
consistent in the movie from page to
screen and the comics flirt khun's can
lay up to 117 eggs possess various
tentacles that extend from out their
mouths and have pocket dimensions inside
their own bodies that must be how goose
was able to store an infinity stone in
there see it all makes perfect sense
Captain Marvel also helps us to make
sense of some previously unseen segments
of the MCU timeline we see the origin of
Nick Fury's eye patch what prompted him
to rename the protector initiative into
the Avenger initiative and some
backstory about Ronan the accuser and
Col rat the pursuer before they fully
broke from the Kree Empire and went
rogue but perhaps most intriguingly the
new film sets up some unanswered
questions about the movement of the
tesseract which holds the space stone
before Thanos crushes it in his bare
hands here's what we know the tesseract
was on earth and a vault being protected
by as guardians until 1942 when it was
stolen by Johann Schmidt aka Red Skull
he loses it at sea and it's recovered by
Howard Stark after the war which he
ultimately passes along to shield now we
thought that shield held on to it until
the year 2012 when it was stolen by Loki
who used it to open a portal into space
and began the Battle of New York in the
first Avengers film but in Captain
Marvel we find out that from at least
1989 until 1995 the tesseract was
actually in the possession of the Kree
scientist Marvel who was keeping it in
her orbiting laboratory and using it to
experiment with faster than light speed
travel so how did Marvel get it did
shield and the Asgardians know it was
missing did they loan it to her is it
possible that these Infinity stones had
all kinds of side adventures we haven't
heard about yet that Marvel will spend
the next several decades filling in who
knows I'm exhausted just thinking about
making all those videos
let's jump to the mid-credits scene
where we see the Avengers who survived
the snaps specifically kept Rhodey Black
Widow and a still apparently Hulk free
bruce banner using Carol's souped-up
space pager it seems like they haven't
made a ton of progress responding to
Thanos yet so we can safely assume that
Carol is integral to their future plans
to set things right when the first
Avengers endgame trailer hit there was a
lot of speculation that one character
seemed to be missing or digitally
removed from all the shots could that be
Carol try to keep up
while we're Ram badly speculating one
more thing to consider in this film we
meet Carol's lifelong friend Maria Rambo
and her daughter Monica and the comics
Monica grows up to be a future Captain
Marvel herself she's currently the hero
known as spectrum but remember this
movie is set in 1995 an Avengers end
game takes place years later so by then
little Monica will have grown up and may
be ready to help her pal auntie Carol
take down Thanos there's even a
reference to Monica potentially flying
through space one day in the movie which
of course she does all the time in the
comics and may do on the big screen
within a few months
Carol's nickname for Monica by the way
lieutenant trouble that's from the
comics - but it's not a Monica Rambeau
reference in the books this is Carol's
name for KITT Renner a little girl who
becomes something of a sidekick for her
hey did anyone noticed that the movie
opens amidst all the dust and debris of
Marvel's experimental ship exploding
kind of looks like that post snap Marvel
apocalypse a little bit right what do
you think will spectrums show up an
Avengers end game how did Marvel get her
hands on the tesseract
I think the mine stone and reality stone
were just floating around in space
getting into trouble in the 90s as well
maybe going to raves or playing hacky
sack hit us up in the comments and let
us know okay catch you on the
flippity-flop I'm Audi 5000
you
[Applause]